i look forward to that good story
we're going old school piper all right
three two we are deep into election
season and election day is just a couple
of weeks away
las vegas weekly's latest is part one of
a two-part election issue
and joining me now on 8 news now is rick
anderson editorial page editor from the
greenspun
media group hi rick thanks for joining
us
well thanks for having me i appreciate
it we appreciate your time
what can voters find in this week's
edition regarding voting
well so we tried to use a golf analogy
we wanted to give voters the information
that they would need to get from
the first tee to the 18th green all the
way to the clubhouse so
you know provide a full list of early
voting locations
places where they can drop off their
ballot provide a full list of candidates
with our
endorsements our recommendations and
then we provide a couple of fun things
like
you know how to hold an interesting
election night party
but yeah just a lot of information in
here clearly you've never golfed with me
rick but i do appreciate the analogy
i'd be looking for golf balls by the
eighth hole but about the pandemic
should people be concerned at all about
voting in person and what are some of
the precautions being taken
well obviously you know that's a
personal uh decision that people will
need to make based on their individual
health situations but
it is worth noting i think that the
county election department is taking a
lot of precautions this year
against the spread of the coronavirus so
you know masks will be required for all
staff
visitors will be voters will be
encouraged to wear masks if they don't
have one
mask will be made available for them or
you know if they really don't want to
wear one
there there will be an alternative way
for them to vote
uh so you know the the machines will be
wiped down between
every use just a lot and
you know clear plastic protective
shields will be placed between
staff and voters just just a lot of
precautions in place
absolutely a lot of effort being taken
to create really a safe environment
now you have an editorial calling this
the most important election of our
lifetime
why exactly are you describing it that
way
well there's so much at stake this year
um for every american and really um
everyone on the planet uh you know
you've got um
social justice issues that will be
decided in this election
you've got the climate uh situation and
all of the effects that we're seeing
from that
you've got voting access itself you've
got health care for
millions of americans so you know with
so much at stake
we're saying that this year it's just
vital for americans to come out and vote
uh you know there are times there have
been times in our history where
ordinary people have made extraordinary
contributions to this country you know
whether it's
congregation members of churches in the
south who
uh you know fought for civil rights or
it was
you know farmers and shopkeepers who uh
grabbed their muskets and and joined the
fight for the revolution
you know it's it's on that scale we
believe this year that
average people can help the country and
can make an enormous contribution by
getting out and voting well said and on
that note what about the people that do
not support president trump
or former vice president joe biden what
is your message to the people who are
considering not voting at all
you know look we get it in a normal year
not
voting is a form of protest it's a form
of
political action this year we just think
there is way too much at stake
to sit out um the way i've described it
to some people
is you know you're outside of build a
burning building
and you have a fire hose and you're not
turning it on that's
like not voting this year of course we
at eight news now and cbs are not in the
endorsement business we're just
reporting on the election in the process
but there will be an endorsement uh in
this issue correct
yes we'll have a full uh slate of
endorsements that means all of the
partisan races uh president congress
the state legislature and so on we'll
also
have our recommendation in all the
judicial races so
i would encourage people to look for las
vegas weekly
at all of our locations and see what
they think of
who we recommend rick from ballot
questions up to the top of the ticket
and the president it's a lot to navigate
i know there's a wealth of information
that will be in this edition and we do
appreciate your time as i said
pre-interview
i look forward to interviewing you again
in the future in studio
oh me too let's get back in there as
soon as we can absolutely thanks for
your time rick
thank you